ja es kommen wieder ins deutsche kleinen
kleinen zurück aus der großen
weltpolitik die
ampelkoalition hat jetzt ihren 100 tage
geburtstag gefeiert ich weiß nicht ob
irgendjemand von ihnen da draußen die
party mitbekommen hat die korken haben
nicht allzu laut geknallt nun kann man
sich fragen ob er was haben sie gemacht
in der zeit wie geht es ihnen eigentlich
das erste große projekt der ampel die
impfpflicht hat keine eigene mehrheit in
der drei-parteien-koalition
die aufrüstung die olaf scholz großartig
verkündet hat da haben die grünen auch
sehr schön geguckt ich bin nicht sicher
ob die mehrheit dafür steht und die
verlängerung von kohle und atomkraft als
ausdruck der eigenen souveränität
scheint mir auch nicht wirklich ein
lieblingsprojekt jetzt in der ampel zu
sein mit anderen worten union muss bei
vielen projekten helfen das ist kein
ausweis von besonders stabilen
machtverhältnissen läuft für die ampel
könnte man sagen die
bundesverteidigungsministerium übt sich
vor allen dingen der waffengattung ab
dann hört man und sieht man relativ
wenig aber sie hat ja immerhin 5000
helme geliefert das lässt sich ja auch
sehen die bundesumweltministerin hat er
dem erinnern uns bei den festgelegten
endzeit klima freundin gemeint dass
ziviler ungehorsam aber dazu gehören
muss hat sie dann später wieder ein
bisschen zurückgenommen und bundes
notarzt karl lauterbach rennt mit seinem
stück josko pum den ganzen haufen rum
und surft von corona welle zu corona
welle also mit anderen worten superstaat
ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau wie das
weitergehen soll aber wenn es so
weitergeht alle achtung
wie ist ihr fazit 100 tage an
na ja ich würde jetzt nicht die ampel
daran messen ob sie das programm oder
die lieblingsprojekte von bild oben
setzt damit sind sie auch nicht im
gespräch als verstehe dass sie das
machen aber das war jetzt nicht um
beispiel wichtiger maßstab für einige
wenn es nicht meine aber
ja ich halte sie zuallererst an dem
gemessen was sie selber im wahlkampf
versprochen haben weil das finde ich ist
immer die geschäftsgrundlage auch als
angebot an die sie wählen und eine
meiner letzten amtshandlungen als ich
noch bundestagsabgeordnete war bevor ich
in die berliner landesregierung
gewechselt habe als der
koalitionsvertrag raus kamen innerhalb
weniger stunden das sozial und
arbeitsmarktpakete zu sichten
wo sozusagen die versprechen auch
umgesetzt worden sind und mir ist
aufgefallen dass im gesamten
sozialbereich faktisch nur zwei projekte
gibt die irgendwie die chance hätten ein
leuchtturmprojekt zu sein und etwas zu
verändern das war die
kindergrundsicherung und das bürgergeld
bei beiden ist mir sofort aufgefallen
dass die aussagen sehr sehr verschwommen
waren und ich habe immer gesagt also
entweder ist das nur ein pr-gag oder es
wird wirklich eine verbesserung und
jetzt wissen wir inzwischen dass im
haushalt dafür nicht mehr geld
vorgesehen ist also insofern befürchte
ich dass auch diese beiden einzigen
punkte das dort sozialpolitisch nicht
geliefert wird und das finde ich sehr
bedauerlich weil ich in meiner arbeit
täglich erfahren wie groß das bedürfnis
ist hier mehr zu tun um kampf gegen
armut
ich hätte vielleicht nicht so ihr
standort an dem sie die menschenwürde
doch wenn man sich etwas vorgenommen hat
dann muss man es auch halten und
insofern ist das auf jeden fall einen
maßstab die frage ist ob das projekt
eigentlich jetzt noch verfolgt wird die
kindergrundsicherung steht auf dem
programm soll wohl diskutiert worden
sein wie man hörte aber ob das priorität
hat oder ob es erst zur nächsten wahl
hin kommt um dann für bessere stimmung
zu sorgen ist wohl noch nicht ganz klar
soweit ich gehört habe und die
bundesinnenministerium haben wir ja in
ihrer performance auch schon hinreichend
bewertet wobei aber noch ausgelassen
haben dass sie der ansicht war wenn man
gegen korona demonstriert kann man das
auch irgendwo unauffällig machen und
muss nicht alles stören das finde ich
für die hüterin der verfassung auch ein
interessantes statement aber es fühlt
sich alles zusammen ich finde es nur
ganz gut wenn man so ins amt stolpert
und holpert dass die umfragewerte
eigentlich einigermaßen stabil sind und
es jetzt nicht zu großen verwerfungen
kommt also die union und die spd liegen
nahezu gleichauf
in der wählergunst hat der ampel der
staat nicht geschadet das muss man
einfach ganz klar sagen offensichtlich
haben die leute auch andere probleme und
können sich nicht ständig um die
neurosen der regierung kümmern
ihr fazit 100 tage ampel also 100 tage
ampel mit blick mit blick auf die
sicherheitspolitik
kann ich zunächst mal zunächst mal
festhalten dass
die ampel regierung
gott sei dank in den ersten 100 tagen
sicherheitspolitisch
keine großen fehler begangen hat also
nichts schlimmes angerichtet hat von
einigen dingen die auch im
koalitionsvertrag
stand in berlin zeigt man ja nicht
gemeckert ist schon gelobt ja
ich erwarte jetzt aber auch nach 100
tagen gerade zu den zu den positiven
dingen die wir dem koalitionsvertrag
entnehmen konnten nämlich die
wiederherstellung der arbeitsfähigkeit
der polizei die lage beispielsweise wo
mir natürlich als gewerkschaft sehr
daran gelegen ist für meine kolleginnen
und kollegen auch das vorhaben das neue
bundespolizei gesetz noch mal mit mit
mit allen befugnissen die dann notwendig
sind zur kriminalitätsbekämpfung und zur
prävention noch einmal anzupacken das
erwarte ich natürlich dass das jetzt
auch passiert da hätte ich mir gewünscht
dass da er mal signale gekommen wären in
unsere in unsere richtung schauen wir
mal vielleicht passiert das sie an die
nächsten 100 tagen
und ansonsten ansonsten ja wir haben ja
nun über die sicherheitslage in
deutschland und europa und in der welt
diskutiert die erwartungshaltung unserer
kolleginnen und kollegen sind sehr groß
und ich hoffe dass das auch irgendwann
erst jetzt im ernst man muss natürlich
auch sagen es ist natürlich auch ein
verdienst dass olaf scholz in der ihm
eigenen ruhigen art den laden so
zusammengehalten hat das mag man als
opposition anders sehen weil man
natürlich jeden riss gerne nutzen möchte
andererseits ist eine gewisse stabilität
gerade in diesen zeiten auch einen einen
schon ein wert bei
angela merkel haben ihr 16 jahre lang
gesagt sie müssen mehr erklären und sie
hat es nicht getan das hat sich olaf
abgeguckt und startet entsprechend in
sein amt der große wurf bei der
sondersitzung des bundestages ganz klar
gestanden hat hat der spd tatsächlich
sogar eine umfrage aufschwung gebracht
dann ist wieder abgeflaut olaf scholz
hat bis jetzt nicht viele fehler gemacht
er ist sogar obwohl dass viele gar nicht
sehen sehr eifrig und fleißig er hat
sehr viele termine empfängt viele leute
führt viele telefonate und zur
krisenbewältigung
das nimmt man draußen nicht so war das
muss man vielleicht zur ehrenrettung der
ampel auch sagen dass es nicht einfach
ist einen laden mit drei
unterschiedlichen truppen zusammen zu
halten wurde eine tankgutscheine
ausgeben will und der andere lieber mehr
windräder aufstellen das ist schon auch
klar also soviel der liebesbrief an
herrn scholz na ja ich wollte jetzt noch
ein bisschen die kurve kriegen
vielleicht kriege ich auch ein interview
oder so was
da jetzt natürlich auch dein fazit noch
aber natürlich mit blick von dir auf
russlands krieg in der ukraine
wie ist dein fazit zur ampel wie haben
sie sich bis jetzt geschlagen
eine außenpolitische und
sicherheitspolitische naivität wie auch
in den jahren zuvor ein totalausfall im
verteidigungsministerium frau lambrecht
die keine ahnung hat von
verteidigungspolitik und dort jetzt als
ministerin 100 milliarden euro extra
budget
betreuen soll wir sehen gerade wie das
schiefgeht ich wünsche mir in so einer
situation nicht frau lamprecht dort die
nie was mit militär zu tun hatte sondern
jemanden der sich auskennt für mich die
positive überraschung um auch mal was
positives zu sagen aber in der berbalk
die außenministerin die sich wirklich
gemacht hat wobei sie sich auch nicht da
genügend durchsetzen kann das muss man
auch sagen ich fand es absurd wie sie
argumentiert hat bei der rede von
selensky dass das doch alles so richtig
war also man merkt politikern an wie
sehr sie sich dieser koalitionsdisziplin
unterwerfen und wie viele schritte aus
meiner sicht vor allem dadurch begründet
sind dass man bloß kein streit zwischen
den drei partnern anfangen will das
sorgt aber für eine gewisse blutleere
weil ich teile deine einschätzung zu
frau lambrecht aber wie es zu erklären
dass sie sich weiter hinhält und
voraussichtlich auch halten wird
das kann ich nicht sagen wie sie sich
halten wird und ob sie sich halten wird
die spd hat sie zur ministerin gemacht
olaf scholz hat sich zumindest drinnen
macht das ja auch vor allem an der
frauenquote muss man ja auch mal sagen
die er dort umsetzen wollte denn frau
lambrecht war ja eigentlich schon raus
aus der politik nur ich glaube man muss
sich dann jetzt ehrlich machen und sagen
wir brauchen jemanden der sich in dem
amt auskennt wenn wir die gefahr sehen
dass wladimir putin mit seiner armee
kein nato staat angreifen kann also ich
fühle mich persönlich nicht sicher in
deutschland werden vor lambrecht
verteidigungsministerin ist frau kipping
fühlen sie sich sicher in deutschland
während frau lambrecht
verteidigungsministerin ist also ich bin
jetzt keine militärexperten das gebe ich
zu ich
wenn ich mich unsicher fühle liegt das
ausdrücklich nicht an dieser personalie
sondern meine große sorge ist und ich
hab jetzt verschiedenste runden mit
militärexperten mir angeschaut und
sachen gelesen und ich merke dass es bei
allen ein ganz großes zögern gibt weil
niemand so 100 prozent weiß welche
handlung unsererseits welche handlung
des westens in welche handlung bei putin
verursacht also ist sozusagen einem mehr
thron vielleicht mehr waffen liefern
führt das zu einem einlenken oder für
das bei ihm zum weiterdrehen in der
eskalationsstufe und wir haben sie mit
dem
machthaber zu tun ich finde dass es
nicht mehr berechenbar der aber zugang
zu atomwaffen hat und der einsatz ist
also ein sehr hoher am ende in krieg und
dem womöglich deutschland beteiligt ist
eine atommacht im spiel ist und man
nicht ausschließen kann dass auch die
atomwaffen genutzt werden also das ist
so das drohszenario mit dem mann zu tun
hatten das macht mir wirklich angst
finde verstehe das bild jetzt
zuallererst irgendwie über
verteidigungsministerin herziehen muss
aber das finde ich es irgendwie der
wirklichen gefahr ja es ist jetzt lassen
sie mich mal meine vorteile aus leben
ist es doch hier sehr reflexhaft wie
wenn eine frau irgendwie die
verteidigung an steht das muss doch bei
ihnen seien effekte negative effekte
auslösen kann aber nicht muss man ja
nicht drin ja auch nicht ihre sprechen
aber ich finde dieses risiko ist doch
nicht in die personalie begründet